AND THE BUCKS HAVE ALSO ONCE
AGAIN, THIRD STRAIGHT GAME, THEY
HAVE BEEN BRUTAL FROM THREE
POINT RANGE.
THEY ARE 5 OF 23.
THE NETS ARE 6 OF 23.
DURANT.
FOUL, AND IT WAS TUCKER.
THAT WILL BE HIS FOURTH.
AND IT'S TUCKER AND DURANT,
GETTING IN TO EACH OTHER'S FACE.
TUCKER NOW YELLING AT KYRIE
IRVING.
YOU HAVE TO BE SMART.
IT WILL BE A DOUBLE TECHNICAL
FOUL, YOU DON'T A WANT TO BE ON
EJECTED.
>> I WONDER IF THEY MAY HAND OUT
ANOTHER ONE FOR A THIRD PLAYER
THAT CAME IN.
IT'S A FOUL.
THAT'S GOING TO BE HIS FOURTH.
AND DURANT SAID SOMETHING AFTER
THAT.
AND NOW, IT'S FACE TO FACE.
AND IT APPEARED TO BE SECURITY
COMING THIS TO, BECAUSE OF THE
SHOVE THERE.
IT'S HARD TO TELL IF TUCKER IS
YELLING AT IRVING OR THE
SECURITY GUARD THAT CAME
BARRELLING IN.
>> ONE OF THOSE -- OH.
I THINK IT'S A DOUBLE TECHNICAL
FOUL.
>> THAT IS FOR SURE.
>> IF YOU ARE SECURITY, YOU HAVE
TO NOT ELEVATE THE ISSUE AS
OPPOSED TO CONTROLLING IT.
>> SO, AT LEAST THESE TWO THE
TEXAS LONGHORNS WHO HAVE A
TERRIFIC R